PRESENTER: This shot was
taken on October 10, 2010.
And so was this.
And this.
There is really nothing
else unifying these scenes--
only the fact that they were
captured on the same day
all over the world.
And according to the guy that
brought all these vignettes
together, that's
exactly the point.
KYLE RUDDICK: I described
"One Day on Earth"
as a community and movement
to document the world,
to share things that matter, and
a participatory media concept
and experiment where anyone
can basically tell a story,
and the collective
stories that we all tell.
PRESENTER: That's
filmmaker Kyle Ruddick
describing his brainchild,
"One Day on Earth."
The idea was to find a filmmaker
in every single country
in the world, and to
collect from each of them
a moment in their day.
And even in 2010, that every
country in the world part
was a real challenge.
KYLE RUDDICK: There's a
lot of the world where just
even getting a video
or a photograph from
is actually a lot of work.
How represented are they
in the global picture?
They're really not as
much as you'd think.
PRESENTER: Though once the
project gained some steam,
Kyle had help.
KYLE RUDDICK: The United
Nations and the Red Cross
and all sorts of other
humanitarian organizations.
And these really came
into play big-time
in the places around the world
where there's no bandwidth.
PRESENTER: Technical hurdles
overcome, the footage flowed
in, to the tune of 3,000 hours.
A real picture of October
10, 2010, emerged.
And with it came
everything you'd
expect from "One Day on Earth."
Excitement.
Fun.
Danger.
Sorrow.
Joy.
Hope.
And everything in between.
And ultimately,
there's a feeling
Kyle keeps returning
to-- connection.
KYLE RUDDICK: The world's
never been so connected before.
But we're just crossing
this thresholds
of like what's it
like when people
in every country in the world
do something at the same time,
or work on something
at the same time?
And I think this is one step in
the evolution of how connected
we actually are.
PRESENTER: In the five years
since this first project,
"One day on Earth" has
spawned more collaborative
documentaries, a foundation,
a social media platform,
and a lot more.
But for Kyle, the soul
of the whole thing
remains in the participants.
KYLE RUDDICK: It was kind of
like, wow, you put an idea out
there.
And a lot of people
grabbed hold.
got inspired.
And they made it their own.
Someone just heard our little
call to do something cool.
And they knew what
their cool was,
and what their
beautiful was, and what
their inspirational was.
PRESENTER: For access to another
unique part of the world,
check out this episode on the
underground town in the middle
of the Australian Outback.
PRESENTER 2: Most of the
residents of Coober Pedy
live in underground homes to
avoid the sun and the heat.
And the man in this photo,
who Elliott called Eddie,
was looking to build a
new home for himself.
PRESENTER: And don't
forget to click Subscribe.
Thanks for watching.